I'm feeling very generous today so
therefore if I laugh I will donate $1
for every life I know I know I'm a
giving man let's try this out oh god
it's gonna be hard because now I J
stop baked now I genuinely don't want to
laugh alright who's keeping the count I
laugh the ones idiot Felix here we go
come on fine I laugh at the first one I
will not get me up where's my volume so
low there we go she says oh that's the
sickest bottle flip I've ever seen in my
life
it's a chosen one he's the chosen one
alright one laugh that was a good one
fine three dollars three see how does
mr. Bies do it how is he still in
business this makes no sense
I'm pretty much gonna break even on this
video since it's January the chances of
being killed by Barney are very low yeah
I've seen this meme float around and I
can't say that I'm that impressed by it
so no I feel like I should remove one
scatter because I was so bad so I'm a
tuna
now now I do not Scott that thank God
tasks failed so six successfully
ah that was amazing
I want to see that again how does he do
that I'm speaking who's commentating on
this I feel like that counts as a laugh
just because it was so beautiful
we're back at 3 this is real I can't
tell I feel like it's fake now I don't
like it anymore can I remove my Scots ah
damn it
$4 you know what they say it's better to
do something than doing nothing or
dollars everyone how antisocial Edwards
prepared to say here when the teacher
calls attendance
[Music]
Capgemini laughed at the comment still
fix it up
why is he boxing underwater teacher
Felix what damn it Oh winning the trust
of people that have put their trust in
us many of them for the first time and
Boris will have my full support as he
does that he's talking to a tree because
it's a good looking tree it's that
simple
it's a fine looking tree I would speak
to that tree don't don't discriminate
tree it almost worked I am so sorry I
feel like that counts as two because
that was so bad oh god we're gonna get
triple digits
I mean double digits oh god this is
gonna get so expensive and I really shot
myself in the foot here this is crazy
I've seen this guy he just yells and I
don't understand what the I don't
understand
kumbaya my man that does not look good
exactly how many people is he cooking
for his wife divorced him before the
show so he took her dog and cooked what
the hell I'm never reading comments
again oh my god I replaced your DNA with
the phone okay well played well played
sir oh we can't play guitar because of
his fingers that's why it was played
epically idiot how does he do that his
fingers are supposed to be he didn't
hate it why did he get his fingers back
that makes no sense
this commercial makes no sense and now
am i angry for long sorry a song
cute Marek you suddenly have the urge to
replay ocarina of time journaling you do
as well let's play on my channel felix
bridge is supposed to go on a break ha
oh my god music this is the fact that
they make these every year they make
every year and this is what they look
like ok news anchor in my lucky hat fat
I can't contain myself it's too funny
yeah it is kind of wholesome but still
this humour in America this is what
humors you is that one tickles your
timbers I don't think so that will not
get my $1 charity money I don't think so
inmates went live and someone try to
threaten them with her jail time this
was their response
yeah I heard that
everywhere in jail they have cell phones
it's just a thing they just sneak them
in how do they keep sneaking stuff in
what who's paying the bill I have so
many questions
isn't that point of jail to be in jail
and can you at least have Facebook or
YouTube face Brian let's see it yeah
yeah he did not holy [ __ ] Family Guy
trickshot I never thought I'd finally
see the day but it finally came but I
didn't laugh so it's okay women aren't
funny I read it in the comment I didn't
say it yeah why did she pour the milk
first how could that is not how it's
done it's at the bite of 87 that is the
crossover I didn't know I needed but I
absolutely did my god that was amazing
I laughed do I usually laugh this much
[Applause]
how does it feel being the meat for once
oh my god I'm the main Hey oh my god so
much power that's a good meme well done
I haven't seen you since last you mean
some people can't take a dad joke
it looks like frost but it's spider
season in Australia burn the whole
country Oh God oh my bad alright well
now we know who did it at least now we
can stop him from doing it again
if you do win an award tonight don't use
it as a platform to make a political
speech right I saw the addition to the
public about anything you know nothing
about the real world most of you spent
less time in school than Greta thumb
burg so if you
I come up exceptionally an award faint
your agent and your God did he just
disrespect my queen
how dare you I feel like this clip was a
lot funnier because they showed Tim what
is the name Tim Cook Apple CEOs face
there is like he's literally sitting
there made by a company that runs
sweatshops in China so okay a couple
things like it's funny right I like this
don't get me wrong
second of all is this is not the fourth
time he hosts the Golden Globe and the
first time he's like I'm never gonna do
this again so like I might as well just
go all-in and that was the whole premise
that's why it was funny because he knew
he was never gonna be able to do it
again here is the fourth time doing the
exact same stick saying oh this is the
actual last time so now I can go all out
sicko mode
are you telling me seriously you never
bought any product that has been
producing China and this is coming for
someone you know me and Marcie we have
our brand Suki where we we produce
ethically in Canada because we want to
avoid sweatshops and obviously there are
legitimate factories in China it's not
like it's all terrible I have something
in my throat my point is what I find in
general is that people don't care where
their product come from and unless
people start caring where their product
are produced then you can't really call
out people like Tim Cook even though I
do agree it's [ __ ] obnoxious hearing
this Hollywood elite preach about a
bunch of [ __ ] because it is tone-deaf I
agree but at the same time I don't
necessarily think his argument really
holds up just wanted to put that out
there everyone that thought he was so
epic when he said that better not be
holding a [ __ ] iPhone that baseball
players hit a ball with wooden stick of
revenge white people
damnit I didn't wanna laugh at that
goddamnit all sports are [ __ ] than
what I get I don't get it I don't
understand I've seen a cricket game and
my god was that boring so I assume
baseball is the same some sports are fun
though like hockey and basketball
they're kind of like high-energy uno
confirms you can't stack plus 4 or plus
2 cards what
then what stop pulling what the hell a
state is that real
there actually happened
[Music]
oh good meme did me yeah I haven't gone
to that episode yet I know feel bar is
in Mandalorian I can't wait to watch
they enter the go to PT PI Nord VP I'm
dr. Peter Pan you can also watch it guys
don't worry
Oh ain't he hit there hard now he will
never become a manager which is probably
for the better anyway because I was a
lame episode when he wants manager I
don't like oh my god they're really
significant Ana's yeah nice okay I know
there was a different cut of the latest
Star Wars film but I didn't know it was
that amazing that lonely ponch hey
people still making tech talks huh
interesting Jesus Christ cringe people
still they get they talk and ironically
you know Jesus Christ oh my god that is
amazing see I've been to Paris and it's
not good it's not a good place to be I
don't want to go all of it what is Trump
say about Paris Paris is no longer
parish but it's kind of true it's fun
girls don't mean to disrespect all right
damn it's good okay what are we at I
think I have a couple more
all right women ruined it that's it
that's all we're doing today they ruin
it they ruin it why am i ruining their
hope you're happy
smash like service guy oh yeah I got a
donate I what do we end up with okay all
right now I feel like a douche bag all
right if you guys all donate a thousand
six-hundred to the wall fire emergency
appeal is that the one in Australia
though I hope they're not scamming me
okay all right yeah save Australia it's
on fire and that's it for me for now hey
though Hey
[Music]
the hour of our spells and poop grades
is coming
marzia Edgar and buttons need your hand
the timer you will face but crawler is
all about
when you are seated on the porcelain
throne Bertie is the game to play I'm
not supposed to have my opinion about
that but the prizes
[Music]
you